hello tiger belly fan there's another
one I'd you want another one I might as
well [ __ ] it we're gonna keep it animal
related alright hello hello Tiger belly
fellow I've noticed that you guys are
pet lovers like me recently I got an 8
week old kitten with my boyfriend who
I've been living with for only 4 months
but been together for two years
this is our first pet together naturally
the kitten is playful and mischievous it
likes to poke around places he probably
shouldn't my boyfriend has never had a
cat but I noticed that he is very
impatient with all animals and gets
angry I'm afraid that he is not going to
be a nice to the kid and it makes me
think maybe he's not the guy I thought
him to be my question is how did Bobby
become the animal lover he is now and is
there hope for my boyfriend to be the
same I say this is Nessa it's a really
important very important question I have
a very important answer to life is you
know when I saw Ming for the very first
time I loved it he loved her yeah and
when Kate wink Ming came to my house and
stayed with me for a couple of days it
was the most exciting and most important
thing in my life I honestly believe that
the aunt animals in my life have changed
me it's made my life fuller and I
absolutely and utterly adore my animals
to the point of almost obsession I love
them like they're humans I think they're
so cute I know the personalities and
they do mistakes but um yeah I mean I
don't get angry I I I'm grateful now do
you think this guy can get to that same
place no you know maybe it was that
would be because I I think that it is an
inherent human quality it's not
something you can tell like you know
richard kuklinski the Iceman Iceman the
guy who killed like a [ __ ] ton of people
one of the first indicators of him being
imbalance was the way he treated animals
I'm not saying your boyfriend's
unbalanced but like at least at the very
least for me some people have different
um you know things that turn them off
for me the biggest turnoff is a man
who doesn't have empathy for animals
even even if they're not mean but if
they're completely apathetic to animals
I don't I didn't turn off by that I
dated a guy who was apathetic to animals
and he had a good reason to be apathetic
it's because his dad had like six German
shepherds and basically loved the dogs
more than him so that wasn't even a good
enough excuse for me I I just got turned
off cuz I know that I can't I love them
so much that I need to share that love
with somebody else and with me and Bobby
it's so easy but I don't know that's a
tough one for me that would be a major
red flag yeah
just but that is me yeah congratulations
John Mulaney for winning an Emmy by the
way oh yeah I love him it's a big thing
[Music]